ah ah
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
et on change d'ambiance j'imagine que
vous avez bien sûr reconnu la musique
c'est celle de harry potter car un
week-end de magie vous attend le jeune
sorcier est à la fête pour un
anniversaire avec nous une fan bonjour
mes amis bonjour camille la wii c'est un
anniversaire pour un bel âge puisque le
premier livre à tout juste 20 ans était
harry potter à l'école des sorciers
alors nous ça ne nous rajeunit pas allée
des spectateurs recevront peut-être un
peu trop jeune pour que cette séquence
mais vous qu amy est ce que vous l'avez
lu et surtout qu'est ce que vous en
retour nous retourner alors je mange
léger lui mais il ya effectivement assez
longtemps comme vous le dites ça
rajeunit pas mais je suis plutôt du film
lorsque les jeunes aux spectateurs aussi
connaissent peut-être plutôt les films
et cet anniversaire et les libraires ne
manque pas de le célébrer notamment à 50
ans oui alors les deux cultures a qui
sont un plaisir et rambouillet eux l'ont
fêté hier jeudi 1er février et ce samedi
c'est au tour des furet du nord à
skywest alors toute une après midi
magique avec différentes activités et on
fait le point et servane qu'est-ce qui
lé responsable de l'enseignent a
commencé par une cérémonie de
répartition avec le choixpeau pour
savoir dans quelle maison on va être
envoyée donc il ya des êtres des
ateliers qui sont pour les plus grands
mais aussi pour les plus jeunes des
ateliers créatifs des quiz des jeux
voilà tout ça tournait autour du monde
des sorciers d'harry potter
on suppose qu'il ne les inscriptions
quand même oui bien sûr pour éviter
peut-être un peu de co et alors il faut
se rapprocher bien sûr de la boutique
via le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran mais aussi les réseaux
sociaux médias pas qu' il n'y a pas que
les furet du nord puisque à versailles
aussi on célèbre le célèbre sorcier
cette fois c'est à l'ère marc l'armoire
geek est une boutique spécialisée
spécialisés ont fait harry potter
jusqu'au 4 février la au programme des
jeux de piste carrément dans la ville
pour retrouver les animaux cachés
il y aussi des photos shootées pourquoi
pas faire un tournoi des champions ça va
rappeler un certain livre le quadrille m
alors là les informations ne sont pas à
trouver dans la gazette du sorcier mais
bien sur le site internet et bien sûr
n'oubliez pas votre plus belle baguette
et votre chapeau de sorcier sinon vous
passerez pour un moldu merci beaucoup
mais la livre de ken maison en fait tu
as à dire on pourrait dire griffonnant
pour seul accroché de l'est plus
le courage